écoutez moi on est là pour s'occuper des
orphelins c'est important qu'ils aient
moins de cinq ans non mais y ait pas de
confusion on n'achète pas des enfants
owni noël j'ai des gars je vous rappelle
300 parents taupe et 2200 euros qui
l'attend dans trois semaines à bordeaux
ça ils ont toujours été hyper créé avec
les parents ils savent très bien qu'il
ya cette pièce tu vas pas l'avoir oui je
vais la voir la pièce est juste tepa sur
le tarmac d'orly
moi je vais pas le choix j'ai un mois
devant moi je fais quoi moi je peux pas
les ramener ces gamins je fais quoi
arrête de se prendre la tête prend les
quatre 4 on va voir les chefs de village
et on avance
il a pris beaucoup de risques pour venir
ici il ya les produits qui auraient des
enfants
sympa non
c'est nous les confient c'est à 100% ou
bien qu'ils sachent les reverront jamais
de la vie
françoise est obligé de filmer un
problème et travaille avec nous et là
pour nous soutenir pour nous aider on va
pas se priver de 5 à 10 heures
j'ai loué un boeing 737 et c'est un 737
qui va dire ici voilà je vous le dis
matin qu on me laissait pas été vulgaire
tu me paies on nettoie aussi fait débat
tout mon temps on en ce qu'ils veulent
c'est créer un incident diplomatique la
france pourra pas renvoyer comme ça à
300 gamins réfugiés de guerre